hey what's up my name's samuel and i'm
amanda and this
is the samuel and amanda show
and this is where we talk about money
marriage and life we do and right now
this is live we are lying in our back
garden
well it's god's back gardener it's free
to use for us it's beautiful we're
right now we're at beach i wish you guys
could see the views maybe we could put
some people so lovely
incredible we are celebrating the
sunshine
and we're celebrating live and
congratulations happy happy birthday
thank you babe you've made it so special
i remember on the last time we did a
podcast you were saying how it might
feel magical too
oh yeah that's true i mean a day a day
of 20 of 29 and it just feels
every day is magical yeah every day is
magical so
in this video right now or if you're
listening on this podcast
we are going to be talking about how to
get into business
whether you are young whether you are
old
whether you are a teenager whether you
are a man a woman
whether you are black white whether you
are um
living in england or not we've got some
basic well i want to give some basic
steps about how you can get started in
business in entrepreneurial
entrepreneurialism that's a long word
and into property
uh so that's really what this this video
is about but first so what have you been
up to
i've been enjoying the sunshine we went
for a day out to peppa pig world which
has really caught the kids
it's been really good weather as you all
know if you're in the uk
and then also i guess just celebrating
my birthday which has been great so
that's been literally the last
and amanda was like oh well let's not do
a podcast today because you know we're
out in the beach and stuff i was like
what sorry i was like this is the
perfect setting
that is lovely my intention is to stay
here
until we are the same color
that's my intention
[Music]
which means that's probably not going to
happen all right so if you want to get
started in business if you want to get
started in property
lots of different things i think i mean
what will be your first what would be
your first
piece of advice you told me one of the
things we talk about a lot is getting in
good circles
yeah i think so i think who you hang
around with is really really important
because
sometimes you can be in a group of
friends that aren't really that
motivated
have totally different interests to you
and stuff and aren't really that
ambitious and
if you're talking to them about all your
dreams and what you want to achieve and
they're not
sort of encouraging you and stuff at
some point you're either just gonna
stay the same and just be like them and
never really progress so i think it's
really important to be around people
that
actually inspire you and want you to do
you know yeah
who you're around is who you become yeah
and you need to step into new circles
and
i think also it's really important to
never be intimidated by anyone i i say
this a lot
when you're stepping into new
environments new circles maybe you're
joining new networks you're going to
property investment seminars
you're stepping into meetings with
people that you've not normally spoke to
before
it's really uncomfortable at first right
yeah i remember when i first started in
property and i bought a cheap suit and i
felt really awkward stepping into
uh business networking meetings going to
estate agents and banks
but a big piece of advice for me is
don't be intimidated i mean i don't know
about you man did you ever feel like
when you're stepping into the business
of the business world
yeah did you ever feel that because i
think naturally
um you sort of compare yourself and you
think oh this person's doing this this
person's doing that
and you can feel like you know not that
confident
but what i always tell myself is that
everyone started somewhere
everyone's you know everyone's been in
that stage where they've been a bit
unsure
felt silly asking a certain question and
that's why i always
tell myself my god this person's where
they are now but to get to where they
are they would have you know been in
this position in the first place so
i think that's how i sort of look in it
and i never like to compare i remember a
few years ago when you start getting
invitations to go and speak
uh events and networking meetings and
stuff and you didn't feel qualified
really no
i know oh i'm just like no thanks
i don't really yeah and i'd really push
you there was like auction houses that
asked amanda can you come and speak uh
she was like i don't want to speak
enough and i was like amanda you are a
quantity
surveyor you've been in property for
years and years it's all you know
you're an interior designer which is our
running joke because
yeah she did a course once but she does
a lot you know so
sometimes you can be intimidated and you
can downplay your own
intelligence or your own success and up
play everybody else's
but actually you know
how do i say this nicely people are a
lot stupider than you think no
really you know if you're watching this
and you're like you know a teenager or
you think i don't really know that much
about probably let me know
most people don't you know estate agents
don't
bank managers don't so if you say to an
estate agent what's the return on
investment on this deal they'll have a
clue
so just just just be confident in who
you are
don't be intimidated by anybody and even
if you do come across a bit dumb
sometimes
you know so what as i'm gonna said we
all started somewhere
so um i think that's really i think
that's really really really important
yeah i've got i've got a list here i've
got i've got some i don't really want to
necessarily read out because i don't
want to get flooded with messages
um but this is this is the uh the old
coffee trick
oh that one although maybe we could call
it the sex on the beach
trip and that's the drink sex on the
beach yeah the drink yes the drink
we're married it's okay we've got the
quiet spot in the beach
so go on talk to me about what about the
coffee trick is when you're at a
networking event or whatever and then
you say to someone
oh you know i'd really like to take you
out for a coffee because you really want
to pick their brain
no that sounds deceptive though you just
up front you just say look i really feel
like i could learn a lot from you about
this that and the other would it be
possible
that i could buy you a coffee for 20
years let's ask you some questions yeah
yeah like you've done this in your
career in the corporate in the corporate
world when you're trying to when you're
trying to progress and learn more and
get on yeah yeah with someone that you
want to learn from yeah i guess so
you just choose to have your life listen
i get it all the time i get people
saying
can i take you out for a coffee and
stuff and i get hundreds of messages
that's why i
set up my training company because and i
run free events
so sometimes it irks me when people say
samuel can i take you out for a coffee
because it's like
i've hired a hotel room
because too many people want coffees
with me so that i can run
a day's training for free and then
people are kind of bothered can i just
have
an hour coffee with you it's like what
so you know that kind of irks me
sometimes that little bit
but i get it i get that it's a great
technique
because people generally will be
flattered that you've asked them for a
coffee because
like if i say to someone that's a bit
more successful than i am six months
ahead of the game or whatever
hey can i grab a coffee with you can i
share some i'd love to pick your brain
on a couple things
you know i i mean most people some
people say no i'm too busy but most
people will say oh yeah i'd be very
happy to help you out
you'd be surprised if you don't ask you
don't that's true
and the worst that they can say is no
but yeah okay really important
don't quit your full-time job yes very
very you took this to the nth degree you
took this to the extreme
i know yeah because when we first got
married i was still in my job
but i also think if you quit your job
sometimes it's really hard
it makes it harder when you want to
purchase a property so
it's so easy the employed life when
you've just got your pay slips and you
know
but when you're suddenly self-employed
actually i think hinders a bit but also
you can do property alongside your job
if you love what you do
you can do it so really really really
really wise
people say to me all the time like
saying i just quit my job and i'm
sometimes like whoa
yeah you know i mean look it's not it's
good to be enthusiastic but you don't
need to quit your job to start a
business
you don't need to quit your job to
become a property entrepreneur or
property investor
do it alongside jim rohn says work
part-time on your
fortune and full-time on your job until
your part-time fortune covers your job
and then you can quit your job and then
you can work full-time on your fortune
which is when it gets really exciting
all right goal setting goal setting
writing down goals
sharing them with people so people can
you know hold you accountable why is it
important to write down a goal
because then it makes it i don't know i
feel like it makes it more real if it's
just in your head
they say it's just a dream isn't it oh
she's dropping the gems
what so you if you have it in your head
it's a dream but when you write it down
it becomes a goal
yeah so so good so good so write it down
speak it out i've changed my stance
slightly on this i don't know what you'd
think
i used to tell everybody to write down
your goals and to tell everybody what
you're gonna do
yeah because then you're hot you're
accountable
that's what i think i think that you
should i changed my mind oh why
over the years go on because there's so
many talkers now everyone's saying what
they're going to do
okay what they're going to do i'm going
to do this i'm going to do this
like you know what write it down maybe
tell one person tell me if you want to
tell me then just go and do it
and then rather than telling the world
what you're going to do tell the world
what you just did
because when you speak out what you're
going to do what you're going to do
people would people will try and
people will try and hold you back true
people will be like and your friends
they want you to succeed but just they
don't want you to succeed more than them
and as soon as you're saying i'm gonna
do that they'll be trying to they'll be
trying to
plot put against you true story man i
didn't used to realize this i thought
my friends won't do that your friends
will do that and if your friends will do
that oh
god help you when you get enemies
yeah no i get what you mean i think that
yes you can keep it to yourself but i
think sometimes when you do put it out
there then
you know you can get someone who you
wouldn't expect actually when you need
help they might say oh actually i can
help you with that
because they know what you're saying so
what do you think
folks yeah should you tell the world
what you're about to do or should you
just do it and tell the world what you
just did
comment below questions for me and
amanda she is filled with wisdom
thank you bubbling out this is like this
is the age of 29 this is what it does is
i think this is what it does is podcast
about to get a whole lot better
oh my goodness don't you good though why
did you stop posting videos
i just i don't know i just sometimes i
feel like i want to be
filming all the time like actually i did
think should i vlog this birthday trip
yeah and i actually haven't but i think
it's just because i'm so present in the
moment i'm not really thinking about i
need to film this for youtube i'm
literally just
enjoying where i am right now so i just
why are you wearing it why you got
michael kors
when you just got new new bags and stuff
what do you mean what the gifts that you
got me yeah well i
brought this bag with me samuel got me
some really nice gifts for my birthday
in fact one of the gifts that you got
was a to-do list yeah you can write down
your goals and turn your dreams into
reality by having them as a goal first
the goal is the bridge to turn into
materials it's nice yeah i got some
really sweet
nice gifts off here sir oh it's been a
great few days man it's been i'm sorry
jacked up i'm so ready to go back in the
ocean though
oh yeah well i think we should have
another dip before we go home yeah
yeah yeah probably yeah why would we
knock
the sun is shining the ocean is if you
listen really carefully you can hear it
going
samuel is it calling you
i was actually listening to him and man
he's like yeah
all right all right um all right next
listen people think i say this because i
run an education company
the actual truth is i run an education
company because i believe this so much
and that's this property is the second
best investment
the best is yourself what i mean by
yourself is your education
because because the more you grow the
more you can
hold and if you are a
small minded broke-minded
not even offensive but just you don't
know much like if you give a million
pounds to somebody they'll lose the
money why because they're not a big
enough container to hold the money
because of what they don't know
or what they do know that's not so oh
right so
and that's been proven through the
lottery whereas when you grow your
container and you become a rich minded
person i'm not talking about your bank
the money will follow if richard branson
suddenly lost everything he'd make it
back again because he's a rich minded
person so
a massive believer in investing in your
education and investing in your personal
growth your knowledge i'm not talking
about necessarily going to university
i'm talking about going on personal
development courses getting a mentor
getting coaches
surrounding yourself with the right
venues with um networks and power team
and specialists
i think it's really important to have
team of advisors um i've created that
for myself
i've opened up for others through things
like samuel 365 of a panel of mentors we
have masterminds
we have unlimited one-on-one mentorship
it's not expensive
i don't get rich off it costs 95 pound a
month and i've got to pay all the
mentors and the expertise to help like
so for me it's a massive massive
important one
so uh what do you think what do you have
to say about that man did you agree i
totally totally agree i think
investing yourself is such a big big
thing i've been on
courses personal development ones and
even obviously the the property training
and i just think that
also when you're in those settings you
meet people that are like-minded which
is what i love the most
so again like we said in the beginning
you know getting yourself into circles
of people that
you know like-minded i think it just all
goes hand in hand and i think it's
really really well it fits with a lot of
what we've talked about the coffee trick
if you're if you're educating yourself
you're around good people that will have
a coffee with you
surrounding yourself with good people
writing down your goals where you're
gonna because when you're learning about
stuff you're gonna obviously implement
it right down
like it just fits with everything yeah
mentored getting trained
and if you've got 50 grand what's that
going to do in property buy you one
house
give you 300 quid a month probably
like whereas if you invest that in
yourself i'm not saying you should
invest the whole 50 grand just
10 of it one percent of it getting some
books and some cds
you know massively gonna help yeah all
right really important last
one is this do
whatever it takes it's going to get hard
in business
it's not all beaches and sunny skies
you're going to have rainy days you're
going to have tough days you're going to
have the door closed in your face and
when the door closes in your face you
have to say i expected that to happen
but guess what
i'm just gonna kick it open or i'm gonna
find another door
you know one of the things that really
baffles me is you know if you if you
know we were driving here to
to um this beach yeah there was a
roadblock and we had to find another
route right remember when we
arrived there's a roadblock yeah and
we're like what do we say did we go oh
there's a roadblock
well let's just wait and wait for the
roadworks to finish
no because that would have been that
would have been ridiculous right imagine
imagine that though imagine saying
there's a roadblock so we'll just wait
for the
works to finish we'll just sit here in
the heat in the car sweating
no why don't you do that because you are
not a complete
[ __ ] what you do is you go oh there's a
roadblock let's find another way
oh my gosh right yes or no true it's
true in business so many people go oh
there's a
there's there's a there's a someone said
no or there's sort of tax change or
there's
this oh there's a lockdown or there's a
oh and they just think oh well i won't
do anything then i'll just continue my
job and wait for the right opportunity
no find another way to get to your
destination
to get to your round goal you know i
think that's very true i think you just
have to be
unstoppable and just willing to just
keep going yeah
nothing worth having comes easy so i
agree
should we go in the ocean yeah let's go
in the ocean guys i hope you enjoyed
this video
we made this we didn't have to do this
we could have just said you know what
it's amanda's birthday
let's not do a podcast let's not do a
youtube video today but we did it
because we are committed to you and to
your learning and to your growth
if you appreciate that please return the
favor by smashing the
like button and subscribe and
notified turn the notifications on got
questions for me i don't think anyone
have any questions for me this week
questions for amanda or for me comment
them below
we'll do our best to answer next week
thank you for watching my name's samuel
and i'm amanda
you